actuellement nous sommes à la paris
games week et il ya beaucoup de gens que
marc sur la droite et sur la gauche aux
caisses du casino derrière cette idée
géniale tiendront beaucoup de gens nous
ont reconnus vous pouvez les voir un peu
pareil si il a pas l'air si il ya pelo
il ya un minable yoyo ya toujours aussi
pour finaliser en fait ouais comme moi
vous pas mais en tout cas c'est sympa on
va pas se mentir brille un peu trop de
gens j'avoue que des fois le prêt qui
peut bien me croque sa candidature j'ai
des gens qui sont derrière
maturi lula lors du match aller
voilà
ils m'ont rapporté ça prend du recul
cette séquence est plutôt nul et vous
faites tous avec une tête bien moche
mais mentir j'ai pas ça va de tout le
monde s'excuse aujourd'hui on est à la
paris games week avec photo et moi
squeeze aujourd'hui à du monde va du web
[Applaudissements]
web
à
[Applaudissements]
sa simple ça on l'a vu quelques-uns sur
la paris games week notamment quoi alors
d'après loin d'hollywood et puis cette
issue sur sneijder est ce possible
[Applaudissements]
tu penses du salon le [ __ ] au niger ça
passe bien pour mon mandat local
avant-hier et l'effet du bourg et donc
tu vois je lui ferais mais je vais faire
sa lettre fois la carte presse c'est à
dire que je suis plus je peux fumer la
base 100 km de là avec tous montés rien
à faire là bas
nagui qui dit le plus petit
[Musique]
au pakistan
et
au canada
[Musique]
o o
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il nous a prévenus position foetale ils
veulent aller position foetale puissance
à quoi le foyer croyez quoi